hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it audrey
hepburn Dear John and Hank katharine
hepburn
damn it I missed the joke we got to redo
the intro hello and welcome to dear Hank
and John or as I prefer to think of it
oh god I did it again damn it Katherine
I'm ready do it I did not anyway it's a
comedy podcast in which being my brother
John and answer your questions bring a
dubious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon and also we talk about how
we're doing and read you a short poem
and tell you about our sponsors and whoa
whoa how do you do it John I'm doing
well I have a bit of a cold so I'm
coming to you today with my husky voice
okay I'm coming to you today with my
half sprite half soda water from Subway
sponsor oh man what I wouldn't give to
get some of that sweet sweet half sprite
half soda water money I call its plight
Oh God because it's so light because it
only has like 70 calories per 12 ounces
that's 50/50 percent of the calories oh
my goodness I can't drink I cannot drink
straight sprite anymore it is so sweet
that I have to do this now in order to
like even it it to me I've gotten to the
point where on not watered down fruit
juices or sodas to me tastes like just
ground-up Jolly Rancher straight into my
mouth I have to say I have also lost my
taste for full calories soda I fear that
this is part of middle-age encroaching I
remember being a kid and seeing all of
the grown-ups drinking diet coke and
thinking that there was nothing on the
earth Sattar than these grown-ups
drinking diet coke and Here I am yeah
our mom had would have just just bubble
water just like flavored but not
sweetened soda water yeah and
I remember one time grabbing one of
those and be like well mom likes these
and having one in just thinking just how
disgusting yeah
that was yeah me too I drink it all the
time drink it all the time the Lacroix
model about the Lacroix John Hanke as I
speak to you I am drinking a grapefruit
Lacroix and it is phenomenal I don't
know I don't know what was wrong with my
teenage tastebuds that they couldn't
appreciate the subtle grapefruit notes
in this Lacroix so many can I read your
short poem yeah okay do that Hank in
honor last week we talked about David
Bowie's death
it's now been like six weeks since David
Bowie died but I've just now gotten the
poem together this actually the lyrics
from David Bowie's song eight line poem
I thought I'd read today in honor of the
great David Bowie the tactful cactus by
your window surveys the prairie of your
room the mobile spins to its collision
Clara puts her head between her paws
they've opened shops down the west side
with all the cacti find a home but the
key to the city
is in the Sun that pins the branches to
the sky eight line poem by David Bowie
it's like David Bowie knew that we were
gonna need a short poem for today and so
he was like well you know it's the 70s
all in in about 45 years somebody's
gonna need an eight line poem and and so
I'll write you one boom well we
appreciate it David Bowie and and all of
your other gifts too to our broken and
only humanity as well Hank should we
answer some questions from listeners
first we've got some general feedback
about the podcast that I want that I
want to check and I want to apologize in
advance for all the times I was wrong
about science this one is from Hamish
who says love the podcast bright spot in
my week there's a herd of feral cows on
Haida Gwaii II off the coast of British
Columbia I nearly drove into one on a
dar
night big shaggy thing keep it up
so there are feral cows out there John
and in British Columbia it does not
surprise me if they're gonna be anywhere
they would be in BC yeah if I were gonna
be a feral cow or a human being and I
could choose any place to live on earth
it would probably be British Columbia oh
really
well unfortunately you probably just
because of the it's relatively mild
climate and relative to and it's in
Canada yeah relative to the rest of
Canada um what I'm trying to do is find
a way to live in Canada but also live in
Hawaii
ideally Canada would invade Hawaii but
short of that I think I'm going to have
to live in British Columbia all right
well I think it would be great if Canada
just annexed Hawaii and then and that
was and then all the people could have
the Canadian laws and Hawaiian weather
that would be that would be the best of
all things you know what Canada doesn't
have Hank what Penny's really don't got
rid of their penny they did yeah yeah I
heard yeah no because they were like you
know what we should do we should be
rational economic actors in the world
and get rid of pennies yes
whereas the United States government is
let's keep spending two cents on these
suckers that nobody uses to facilitate
the exchange of goods here is the the I
recently heard an argument for the
existence of pennies that I agreed with
oh shut up
dee dee I know I know I I was shocked as
well do you want to hear it hold on I
gotta have a sip of that grapefruit
lacroix to get ready for this crap
okay well I I think that you will agree
to some extent that it is not a terrible
reason for pennies to exist okay bring
it in a lot of nations that are not
America yeah they nonetheless use
American currency correct and in those
places the difference between one cent
and five cents is a big difference for
example a bus fare might be seven cents
and going down to five cents would
economically you know would not work for
the people running the bus line and
going up to ten would be a huge hit to
the people who take that bus and and so
like a 1 cent increase in bus fares for
example often increases and often
results in protests in like like
significant problems economic a for a
couple things so I just got to cut you
okay because you're so wrong alright
okay so in this hypothetical this is a
real thing world I assume we're talking
about like maybe Venezuela in nineteen
seventy two know so but IIIi heard this
from a congressional staffer there is no
place on earth right now where US
currency is used for bus fares that are
part of the public service of a country
other than the United States because
nowhere on earth other than the United
States is the US dollar and official
currency so putting the bus example
aside there are places where goods are
somewhat less expensive than they are in
the United States or where less
expensive goods are frequently traded or
less expensive services are frequently
traded in exchange for currency in none
of these places none of them is anything
worth a penny because pennies are less
than worthless but if that were true and
if someone can show me an actual example
of that being true I will slightly
revise my opinion on pennies too that we
should no longer mint them except
insofar as there is demand for them and
we should begin rounding immediately all
of our transactions in the United States
to the nearest dime so we got another
question for this this is from Allison
it's not a question just another comment
you both especially John like discussing
how many things will will lead to
widespread death I really enjoy
listening to your comedy podcast yet I
find myself wondering if there is really
anything
the world that will not lead to
widespread death yeah Purell yeah I
guess I guess Purell will not lead to
widespread death but nothing does lead
to widespread death like the there will
inevitably be widespread death but the
question is will there also be
widespread birth right dude that that's
that's sort of like will the widespread
death be be spread out over a relatively
long you know a normal sort or will Lily
spikes spikes is the thing you want to
avoid a nice level death rate absolutely
fine and wonderful and and that's that's
of course what we're going for what we
want is for the same number of people to
die pretty much every year well ideally
we'd like that number to go down and in
fact I was sort of shocked to find that
it does go down because it seems like oh
no you know people die and so the number
of people who get born in the number of
people who die and it's just like if it
should be the same over time but it's
really not the number of people who die
per year has decreased substantially
yeah oh no it's it's just innate become
it's so much better to be alive today
than it was like fifteen hundred years
ago it's almost it's difficult to even
calculate it but yeah the global the
essentially the global death rate has
dropped dramatically like it's dropped
by almost half right but the thing is
like you wouldn't necessarily think that
because the rate has decreased that the
number has decreased because it seems
sort of like well the number of people
who die is equal to the number of people
who are alive in the long term birth
rate as a live as they also dropped a
lot yes
yeah but as they as people live longer
fewer people die per year because you
have more years in which you can die
right
so m'avez counterintuitive and it took
me a little while to get my mind around
the fact that actually fewer people die
per year which is neat so yes we want
the number of people who die per year to
go down
slowly or as quickly as possible no
spikes so when we talk about widespread
death what we're talking about is spikes
in the death which we really do not want
those that is what we are trying to
avoid and the last comment we have from
a listener this is from Lauren just
wants us to know that the insight Lander
which we talked about being delayed
substantially a few weeks ago her father
is the lead propulsion person at
Lockheed on that mission which is super
cool isn't that I don't know I just like
that the world is small and the people
are doing cool things John and and look
well I I wish her father great luck
getting that thing to Mars all right
John let's do some actual questions go
now I think we've got a question here
from Andy who writes Dear John and Hank
I'm working on a production of The
Wizard of Oz and every day after giving
the Tin Man his heart The Wizard says
remember my sentimental friend a heart
is not judged by how much you love but
by how much you are loved by others this
rings false to me if you agree or
disagree with the wizard and why thanks
for your question Andy yeah so one of
the things that I've noticed over the
years is that things that sound like
aphorisms often become sort of used in
common language as if they were true
even though when you really look at them
they aren't the the best example of this
to me is from the book love story which
was turned into this big hit movie it
was this you know tragic story really
The Fault in Our Stars in some ways I
like built as sort of a response to love
story or trying to like address some of
the things that I saw as romanticized in
it but it was this huge hit book in the
70s and the famous line from it that was
in common discourse for decades
afterwards was love means never having
to say you're sorry which of course is
ridiculous
and that if you don't ever say that
you're sorry what a meanie you're being
to this person you love
I do think that there's something about
the Wizards line here that I find
troubling because loving is is is
important just as being loved as
important and I don't think that you can
really fully separate them yeah I I
don't think that we should take what is
written in especially said by characters
and books as definite truth I mean
obviously the wizard is supposed to be
this big wise man that's probably where
the wizard wizard comes from now that I
think about it from wise hard
he's a wise ardh and but yeah I I think
that the way that you think about love
it should be the way that you think
about love yeah I just I don't buy the
idea that a heart should be judged
either way by how much it will absorb by
how much it is loved who's doing the
judging the wizard yeah I don't know I
I'm troubled I'm troubled by that line
even though there's a lot that I like
about The Wizard of Oz I got another
question from Brandon who asks dear Hank
and John so you know how California has
a water shortage why can't they just
hold a big magnifying glass over the sea
to create water vapor and then collect
that salt free water vapor and then
condense it into usable water love the
show well I do know that that in science
fiction I have seen this idea it was not
used to in in the book I'm thinking of
it was not used to create water vapor it
was used to create a number of other
gases and also to build a canal so
basically burning a ditch in the earth
and and connecting to bodies of water
but yeah I mean you you would have to
have a way of lifting that giant
magnifying glass into the air which
would be extremely energy intensive and
keeping it there the the one potential
thing you could do is actually put that
in orbit or build it in orbit so that it
is either a mirror or a or a magnifying
glass that is focusing the sun's energy
on the water now you are also going to
have a ton of ecological consequences
here so like as you are boiling this
water you are also heating up the water
which means that you're changing the
the local like temperature of the sea
dramatically which is going to really
affect the the aquatic life there it's
gonna mess up that and and then you have
to collect this this this water which
you probably wouldn't do you would
probably just have it rise up and only
do it on days when the wind was blowing
the direction you wanted to blow and
then it would fall on the land which is
great because you know then you you
don't have to create any new
infrastructure you just recharge the
aquifers and the water falls on the
crops and it's all good so yeah it is
not it is not something that would not
work it is probably more energy
intensive though than just creating a
desalination plant which is extremely
energy intensive which is why they
haven't done that yet but they might and
in the long term have to do that in
desalination or desalinization I think
those words mean the same thing probably
in the long-term future for California
which is kind of scary well I think that
everyone should just move right here to
Indianapolis where we have tons of water
we just we almost have too much of it
it's probably probably difficult to move
all the all the you know fruit trees
that have been growing there for the
last 200 years but no they do great here
are you kidding we can grow a tangerine
like nobody's business here in
Indianapolis it's 4 degrees outside
right now does that affect things at all
[Laughter]
alright we've got another question this
one is from Katherine who writes Dear
John and Hank I recently saw the movie
inside out and it made me think about a
quote from The Fault in Our Stars this
is a very controversial quote from my
novel The Fault in Our Stars by the way
Hank the existence of broccoli does not
in any way affect the taste of chocolate
inside out seems to argue the exact
opposite that without sadness we can't
truly feel joy I was wondering what you
two thought of inside out and its
overall message especially with this
quote in mind what would our lives be
like if we had never suffered is
suffering necessary for us to see the
beauty in life yeah I feel like John
you've thought about this way more than
me so like I I cannot really wrap my
mind around this cuz I don't know what
life would be like if I hadn't lived the
way that I have well of course I also
don't and
don't know if if joy is sweeter for
having suffered or if the more you
suffer the sweeter joy becomes what I do
know is that a lot of times people use
that idea as a way of telling people who
are suffering what to feel or as a way
of telling people who are suffering what
the meaning of their suffering is and
that strikes me as dehumanizing and
infuriating and I think that's what
hazel was responding to in the novel
when she said that but she does say the
existence of broccoli doesn't affect
affect the taste of chocolate not the
taste of broccoli doesn't affect the
taste of chocolate because of course the
taste of broccoli does mean literally
affect the taste of chocolate like if
you eat it immediately before
immediately after like it does it does
affect the way that your tastebuds
respond to chocolate if you had broccoli
flavored chocolate or like chocolate
with broccoli bits in it then definitely
definitely affect the flavor of the
chocolate myself I like both broccoli
and chocolate so I don't have a problem
with this false dichotomy that haze was
created and in my book but anyway I
can't speak to what life would be like
without sadness I I do not however buy
into this argument that that we suffer
so that we can learn lessons or that we
suffer so that we can become you know
better more grateful more joyful people
I think there are cheaper ways to learn
these lessons than the kind of suffering
that many people live with and I and I
and and if that's if I'm wrong about
that if some people find comfort or feel
that feel that their lives you know
become richer through suffering then
maybe maybe I'm wrong but I don't what I
don't want to do is impose this
worldview upon others when they are
going through hard times that they may
or may not find transformative or useful
huh yeah I mean I think that there a lot
of it isn't about joy or suffering it's
about the feeling of
of like what a good life is and and I'm
sort of playing with this idea very you
know cursorily here I don't I don't have
a lot of haven't really developed this
the line of reasoning but that it's more
about what is seen as a good life and
and there is a lot about how we live our
lives that isn't really about bringing
bringing joy into our lives it's about
how to feel as if we are having a good
one and you know obviously now we have a
great deal more luxury just by virtue of
like hot water coming out of our houses
and the internet and being able to
choose from a number of different
cuisines every night that we did not
previously have as as like Americans and
also as humans and and so like it's nice
like because those things are like like
hot water is a great example that is
something that most people in America
have and most people in America take for
granted and what a lovely thing to be
able to take a hot shower on a cold day
and it and every time I do that I try to
think how lovely it is despite the fact
that I've always had that luxury I tried
to remember what a great luxury it is
and that most people who have ever
existed have not had that luxury yeah
and I see your point that you probably
can't appreciate that in the way that
someone who is taking their first hot
shower would appreciate it I guess for
me you know my thinking when I was
writing that was how often we we hear
these these narratives because of
because of the way we construct what
constitutes a good life we often hear
these narratives of well I went through
this and I came out on the other side
stronger healthier happier more joyful
more grateful whatever but what if there
is no other side you know for hazel
there really is no other side there is
there is not going to be a time in her
life when she is what other people would
call healthy you know there is not going
to be a time in her life when she's you
know completely
able-bodied and she's not getting better
you know she's just living in this sort
of stasis where you know she's able to
treat her cancer but she's not able to
cure it and and I think saying to those
said you know imagining what what
constitutes a good life and excluding
someone like hazel is really troubling
to me and that's that's where the idea
came from I certainly don't want to
argue that you know everyone has equal
access to the same kinds of joy at all
times or anything like that yeah I don't
know
I myself have mixed feelings about the
quote but what can I do the book came
out
well said John well said I think that
that that means a lot to me as a person
who likes your books a lot and that is a
very separate thing of course then the
question but I really do appreciate how
how intense and weird it is to have
after four years later have have a book
that you know a lot of people love and
and and to not you know of course not
feel like it is anyway in any way
perfect or you know something that you
something it's still something that you
have mixed feelings about and and like
you know obviously I think that you I
like that book a lot I've read it a lot
of several times since it came out and
it's it's so interesting to you know
that you are my brother and so I see you
as my brother and not like the the the
sort of way I feel about my favorite
authors is very different from the way
that I feel about my brother and and and
yet you are also one of my favorite
authors so it is it's always really
interesting to hear you talk about the
complexities of your relationship with
your work thank you I mean it's
definitely a difficult thing to have
something out in the world for years and
years after you were last able to touch
it and change it and of course you know
I've I've changed and learned since then
but you never know if that makes you a
better writer or a worse one I
I always think about WH Auden um you
know later in his life going back and
revising all of his poems and and he
felt so strongly that he was making them
better and he was making them so so much
worse there's you know the probably the
greatest most quoted line of WH Auden
poetry is we must love one another or
die and he later edited that - we must
love one another and die which is more
true but less good it's like he forgot a
different in the intervening years yeah
there's a lot of examples like that
where you just you read the edited
versions to the poem and you're just
like oh my goodness how did you convince
yourself that this was a step in the
right direction
so my feeling is just that you know my
all of my books you know even the day
after they come out I have to say to
myself like this is something that I did
in a period of my life that reflected my
very best attempt to to you know write
the best story I could and that's that's
all it is you know like it's a snapshot
of that of that time of that of the
creative output that I was capable of in
that moment and or in those years or
whatever and that's all it can be and
you have to let go of it and you have to
you have to let it have a life that's
separate from yours I mean one of the
weird things about having the Fault in
Our Stars come out and reach such a
broad audience is that lots of people
have interpreted it in ways that I am
frankly uncomfortable with you know
books belong to their readers but there
there is still an author out there
thinking no no that's not what I meant
at all yeah and you just have to live
with that you know like if if you if you
hear from someone that The Fault in Our
Stars taught them to be grateful for
every day even though hazel makes fun of
that within the very text of the novel
like you just have to let it go yeah he
said clearly not letting it go okay
here's another question John it's from
Adam who says dear Hank and John you
recently spent a lot of time talking
about your apocalypse fears as a
geoscientist I was distraught to learn
that some of the most exciting and
potentially
the stating geologic catastrophes didn't
make the list John have you considered
how far from the Yellowstone
supervolcano you live Hank do you how
ready do you think humanity is to
deflect a large asteroid if one were
discovered to be about to strike us the
these along with sudden rapid climate
change are my top three apocalypses the
ones that tend to keep keep me up at
night those are all potential
apocalypses that I am aware of the
Yellowstone supervolcano does not bug me
that much despite the fact that I live
very close to wait what is the
Yellowstone supervolcano how is it going
to kill all of us and when is it going
to erupt
so Yellowstone National have you ever
been to Yellowstone John yep
so Yellowstone National Park but I'm
never going back one of the most frankly
if if the Yellowstone supervolcano were
to erupt
I think the Yellowstone National Park
would be the best place to be because
you want to die fast oh good lord
okay great it depends on which way the
winds blowing literally
but the Yellowstone National Park is one
of the most beautiful places on earth it
is a really a fairly untouched
wilderness but one that has a road
running straight through the middle of
it so that you can go see some of the
more spectacular parts of it and those
spectacular parts are generally driven
by geothermal activity the park itself
is mostly inside of a caldera of a
volcano that I don't know how long ago
it was but it was a very long time ago
that erupted and but I cast ash over the
majority of North America alright
it is it is erupted many times and and
we are aware of you know we can sort of
see in the geological record four or
five of those and it is it is a it is
the big it is at least one of the
biggest volcanoes on earth it is when
you are inside of the Yellowstone
Caldera you do not feel like you are
inside of a caldera because it is so
large you basically just feel like
there's some mountains around but really
you are in a crater that that was formed
when a huge like basically you know an
area of like I would not be surprised if
you could fit Rhode Island inside of it
though I'm sure you can't a very large
area was just ejected into the
atmosphere and that where what then
happens is a long period of time that
does not have normal amounts of sunlight
which changes the weather very
dramatically and it potentially would
result in an inability to grow food and
that would be the thing that would kill
a lot of people in America it would
probably have a really significant
global impact as well but people there
would be a lot of people in America who
would just immediately die just by being
Barrett buried in ash this is not likely
though this is not something that
happens every five years know this this
uh it's you know people will say like
we're due for one but what that means is
that they occur it within a certain
number of years from each other and that
we're sort of roughly around like we're
inside of the the time in which this
could happen again but if it were going
to happen again there would be a number
of tremendous geological changes that we
would be seeing the the this these
eruptions happen after a lot of pressure
starts building up underneath the you
know the caldera yeah and what you would
see is is literally the ground would be
rising at the rate of feet or meters per
day
oh god so that they're nowhere near that
though they're their hat there is a you
know there is like flecks in the the
ground in Yellowstone that it will rise
and fall by feet and meters per year
which is really remarkable and and they
you know they've only been doing
research on this stuff for the last 50
years or so but we are not seeing
anywhere like the kind of geological
activity that would result in the Osten
super volcano erupting but and so
basically my my guess is
that we are thousands of years away from
the super from from that volcano
erupting all right and so it is not
concerned what about the asteroid
asteroids they're more of a crapshoot
which is why I don't concern myself with
them because you can't really know and
what we're doing right now to try and
get a better get a better handle on the
you know the near-earth objects is I
think appropriate and if if we
identified a near-earth object that was
going to strike earth that was large
enough to be concerned with
I would actually kind of like to see
humanity band together and take care of
that because I feel like it's something
that we could take care of and and I
would let I would like to see us do it
don't you also think though that we
might we might have a lot of debates
about whether the asteroid is really
gonna hit earth or whether the science
might be wrong about this and now this
is gonna be a future generations problem
not our problem no I think I think that
NASA probably NASA would find it first
they would ask other observatories with
on the order of days to weeks to confirm
and then it would be confirmed I don't
think that it would be it's not it's
it's pretty easy to figure that stuff
out so you're saying there would be
widespread scientific agreement that
this asteroid was about to hit earth my
counter-argument to that would be climb
climate change yeah I think that I think
that asteroids are much scarier than
climate change despite the fact that
climate change is actually a much more
significant threat and I do agree with
Adam I was gonna say I'm I'm much more
worried about climate change than I'm
worried about asteroids and that's
saying something because I can worry all
right well I think we've spent a lot of
time on Adams Adams question but I you
know it's dear Hank and John so we can't
not spend time talking about the
apocalypse speaking of which Hank did
you know that today's podcast is
actually brought to you by sudden rapid
climate change sudden rapid climate
change a thing that many people think is
impossible just not scientists this
Vargas has also brought to you by
broccoli flavored chocolate something
about
which John feels ambivalent because in
fact broccoli in this case does affect
the flavor of chocolate and of course
this podcast is also brought to you by
California's water shortage California's
water shortage don't worry we'll put a
huge magnifying glass in space all taken
care of
I love it we're gonna do one last
question John does that sound okay to
you sure alright this one is from Paula
who asks dear Hank and John I just found
out that the amazing Stephen Colbert is
a fan of the mountain goats that his
favorite planet is Mars and that he's
basically the biggest Tolkien geek the
world has ever seen I think that's just
one step away from becoming a lifelong
nerdfighter
is there any secret plan that has
evolved about how to act in these kind
of situations what shall we do crash The
Late Show with an army of puppy-sized
elephants well you know Hank I had the
chance to meet Stephen Colbert not too
long ago I had the coolest thing about
it I mean I was generally very very
impressed with him he came in and talked
to me a bunch about the show he was like
I play a character I'm not really that
person and I was like I've seen the show
man and he was like oh thanks thanks
thanks for your support I was just like
do people come here who haven't seen the
show anyway in between segments of The
Colbert Report his previous show he
played the exact same Neutral Milk Hotel
song every time and he he told I was
like I love this song and I love this
album and he said yeah I love it too he
said every every taping I try to find
someone in the crowd who's singing along
with it and lock eyes with them and then
we sing the words together and I was
like that is so cool Stephen Colbert
that is so like I'm so glad that you
told me that after our little bit
together because I could not have
handled meeting you if I knew it before
[Laughter]
this is a very unrelated story but I was
at a hockey game recently the Missoula
Mozilla has a very small hockey team and
what's what's the mascot the mall the
mascot is slash who was a wolf
they are the Mahler's I'm very
ambivalent or
is gonna go ahead and say that I do not
like that our hockey team is called the
Mahler's and that my mascot is a wolf
because there is a lot of like sort of
anti wolf sentiment in this part of the
country and I I'm not a part of it
but anyway I I was at this this hockey
game and and shut up and dance by walk
the moon came on one of my favorite
favorite songs of 2015 and yeah a girl
is walking to her seat and she's singing
along with just it these dead dead eyes
and shut up and dance very fun you know
sort of summertime and she's just like
singing Sid Joe's every word but like
she's somewhere else she does not know
that she's singing along she's thinking
about her algebra test and how she did
very poorly on it but she is mouthing
those words - shut up and dance no
problem and I was just like I've never
seen a more sad person singing along to
walk the moon shut up and dance peg do
you know where walk the moon formed
Indianapolis Indiana incorrect they
formed at my alma mater Kenyon College
in Gambier Ohio oh thanks for staying
there so many famous people coming out
of Kenyon College so many you those guys
Allison Janney I don't know who that is
she's the press secretary on on the west
wing and also she's been in a million
movies Oh CJ Cregg yeah I know she's
great I love her she's great let's move
on to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon Hank do you want to go first
or do you want me to or do you want to
do rock-paper-scissors oh yeah I want to
do rock-paper-scissors junk alright
ready one two three
three paper I did pay for two okay one
two three paper scissors
oh did you wait to say scissors until
after I'd said paper Oh Matt's just a
little bit of a lie oh I don't know I
don't know if that was lag but okay you
go first it's just a little bit of lag
all right we got some news
from the federal government on December
18 2015 and I know that's a little dated
now but we're catching up still from the
break President Obama signed the
spending bill the budget that
the federal government through the
fiscal year of 2016 which included
nineteen point three billion dollars for
NASA an increase of 1.3 billion from
last year so the huge hunk of that is
going toward the line-item that includes
Orion and the Space Launch System and
that is the the new rocket that is going
to be taking astronauts to the space
station and beyond and beyond
includes possibly an asteroid mission
also includes possibly a Mars mission
and that actually got more money than
they asked for which is great because
that is that is sort of on the on the
trajectory toward getting big payload
missions to Mars bigger payload missions
than we've been able to do before and
that could potentially include having
humans involved in those missions so
thank you to the federal government for
continuing to fund NASA and humanity's
reach into the next the next our next
foothold in the solar system that could
hopefully be Mars whoo and
congratulations to the United States
Congress on passing its first budget in
like seven years it's just amazing so
proud of you people said you could never
do it that you'd only fund the fund the
federal government for a week at a time
and you did that you kicked the can down
the road for like years and years but
then finally you did it assigned a
budget great work guys in AFC Wimbledon
news Hank AFC Wimbledon as I'm recording
this still hasn't played a game since
their astonishing astonishing 4-1
victory over Cambridge United which was
good also for their goal difference but
Hank the under eight team team which I
talked about beating Newcastle last week
now Hank I'm sure you recall what
happened
the reason AFC Wimbledon was formed in
the first place right yes I know all
about that story basically that there
was a team Wimbledon FC that had a
wonderful history going back to the
1800s and then it was stolen away from
them
when the English Football Association
the governing body of English football
declared that Wimbledon FC would be
moved and do you remember where they
were moved to they were moved I don't
John I don't Milton Keynes
yeah that's not ever gonna stick and so
they became they called themselves the
MK Dons because they claimed some
semblance of history associated with
Wimbledon which is complete crap and
they need to stop saying that but
they're just a franchise basically
they're not a real Football Club
however they play as if they were a real
Football Club and in Milton Keynes they
have some support and I don't begrudge
people who supported who began
supporting them after the move anyway
long story short occasionally
AFC Wimbledon will play Milton Keynes
the franchise I once heard by the way
Hank a radio commentary of a game
between AFC Wimbledon and Milton Keynes
in which at no point did either of the
announcers to say the word Milton the
word Keynes or any of the player names
um they were referred to only as the
franchise and they would be like and now
the franchises right winger has the ball
and now he has passed it to one of the
franchise's forwards it was amazing
there is unfortunately still one Milton
Keynes player who was a Wimbledon player
and I have never heard a player booed
that consistently over ninety minutes in
my entire life I felt bad for the kid
he was just signing the only
professional contract that he had access
to it felt like he couldn't say no but
boy who he as he lived to regret it
anyway okay
the under-18 team every time AFC
Wimbledon plays Milton Keynes in any
capacity whether it's the you know the
seven year old girls team the you know
the 13 year old boys team whatever it is
it is a big game right because this is
the team that essentially forced AFC
Wimbledon into existence by stealing
away the club so it is a big game like
it's essentially a game like for
instance when Milton Keynes and AFC
didn't play the AFC Wimbledon's
supporters always sing to the milton
keynes supporters who were you who were
you who were you when you were us
which which I think puts a nice period
on on the situation so when the under-18
team played Milton Keynes it's a big big
game even if it's just a youth game and
AFC Wimbledon won 2-1 sending the
franchise right where it belongs to
ignominy yeah big the minute II yeah
yeah who were you when you were us it's
just that that is the greatest chant
I've ever heard in football I think it's
just so perfect the other one they sing
is stand up if you own your club because
everybody who supports AFC Wimbledon is
also an owner team I should add by the
way Hank that AFC Wimbledon not because
I am a celebrity sponsor of the club or
anything AFC Wimbledon sent both of my
children Christmas card my children are
both members of the Junior Don's they
sent both of my which cost like $25 a
month if you're under 18 you can be a
Jew not not $25 a month $25 a year if
you're under 18 you can be a junior Don
for $25 a year if you're over 18 you can
own part of the club for only like $80 a
year and you get to be an owner of the
team and support this great institution
anyway they sent Henry and Alice both
cards signed by a bunch of the players
including audible aachen fella Henry's
favorite player it was so cool of them
they do that every year they send Henry
and Alice birthday cards and Christmas
cards every year signed by the players
it's so sweet it's so awesome I think it
says a lot about the kind of club that
they are yeah so I wanted to say thank
you for that as well all right I
appreciate that thank you to AFC
Wimbledon for being pretty cool I think
cooler than most football clubs though
that does not necessarily manage to hold
my interest they are a lot cooler than
most football clubs and don't worry all
the talk about Marv
bores me as well alright thanks for
podcasting John what did we learn today
well we learned that there are feral
cows on an island off of British
Columbia livingmydream
it's pretty remarkable we learned that
John Green has complicated relationship
with the things that he's created and
has to just let them go which he cannot
do and of course we learned a new reason
to fear the end of the world
a gigantic Yellowstone volcano and/or
comet coming from space and or rapid
climate change and of course we learned
that the things that Hank and John are
scared about it not people dying was
that we are in favor of people dying at
the same or lower rate than they
currently are but what we want to be
afraid of are the spikes avoid the
spikes we hate the spikes we are
strongly opposed to spikes and we
learned of course that The Wizard of Oz
is a truly wise art I wonder if that's
the actual etymology of that word I
would be interested to find out and in
fact I'm gonna find out while you do the
outro here
well I art I already looked it up it is
from wise ardent surely I don't know
what it is but I'm clicking on art
oh it is it forms a noun it's like
saying a Y Z guy like a wise guy or a
card but Roy a drunk guard yeah drunkard
yeah all right neat thanks for making a
podcast with me John and confirming that
my etymology is correct
uy Zard that that word by the way art
really reached its its pinnacle back at
about 1730 and it's been steadily
declining insignificant since but we
still have wizard and drunkard that's
something all right thanks so much for
listening to dear Hank and John you can
email us at Hank and John at gmail.com
with your questions you can also use the
hashtag dear Hank and John on the
Twitter where I'm John
Hank is Hank green spot gas is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins our theme music is by
gunnarolla and as we say in our hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]